hey everybody out there time for another
movie retrospective I knew we didn't a
new one kind of a new one last time cuz
we did train to Busan but on this
installment we were going back again to
the 1970s a very well-regarded TV movie
the TV movie from 1975 yeah this is
trilogy of terror yeah Oh Karen bad
Karen black thing that's like three
movies it's kind of like the prototype a
like a prototype for um creek show a
little bit yeah you know I think I might
have a little bit better but this was
good too though yeah I mean considering
that this was made for TV in 1975 was
actually made for ABC it was their movie
of the week yeah and it's kind of an
unusual it's an anthology film obviously
and it has three different segments it's
so much short I think it's only like 75
minutes but it has kind of an unusual
conceit to it in the sense that all
three segments were based on stories by
Richard Matheson and all three stories
star Karen black layering different
roles sexy as Karen black there is
something very like Edinger I don't know
what it is it's like she was and it's
funny because before she did this I mean
she was actually she was in five Easy
Pieces she was an Easy Rider she was in
like a lot of really big movies and then
kind of went off into horror later on
got that Walt Disney damn knows where
the bridge of her nose goes way back and
she was like a Walt Disney character
inside yeah that's part of it she's
she's tall and she's good-looking and
she has looks like slightly a lazy eye
that kind yeah kind of makes her look
she's a little bit cross-eyed that was
my dad's favorite actress my dad was
just so crazy about and really what I
remember about this one kid my dad when
I first saw it I was sitting on down
living room floor playing with trucks
and [ __ ] are UFO's
my dad was watching it and it had it
nd warrior that dolls anywhere Jimmy
Warrior yeah a little-little damn
enchanted doll and that's what's stuck
with me over the years I feel like that
segment is pretty much the main thing
that people think of when they think of
this movie um you know I I've seen it
several times over the years
and I actually like all three of the
stories but I do feel like most people I
mean pretty much 99.99% of everyone that
I've ever like looked at that read that
reviewed this movie is like pretty much
the only the third one is any good but
yeah I would disagree with that yeah the
other ones are more story based and that
last one is more kind of like action and
sand and special effects based and it's
almost kind of like a prototype for
gremlins where you got one little
creature that you got a fight against
there was a there was a episode of The
Twilight Zone that when I was a kid yeah
reminded me a lot of the same one and
that was the one with the agnes
moorehead yeah plays an old woman living
in a shack out in the damn desert and a
little UFO lands up into a roof and she
starts fighting these little men from
space and there's a pan of ray guns yeah
I remember that and then the very end
you find out you know she kills them all
and then starts busting up the damn
flying saucer and it says US Air Force
on the flying saucer
I hear a transmission you know you know
this is you know this is the Mars
exploration you know back to earth don't
come to Mars it's inhabited by giants
now she was a Martian but you think
she's just some woman in the Old West
you know yeah a tiny yeah that's what
the name of that episode was and I was a
good episode man it was that was one of
them that was a kid that one just really
stuck with me that wasn't the idea these
little toy size things fighting you yeah
man and then the idea of this in this
man this movie trailer to your Terror
something the size of a doll a doll
coming in [ __ ] you up yeah yeah cuz I
had little dolls like little Boba Fett's
there's like that big I had the damn
alien doll from alien I had Boba Fett
and it just kind of was like man what if
that came after you
yeah you'd be interesting weird you know
but you know you it it kind of holds up
today dad it is very 70s but you know
what I mean it's like there is something
about that era and a lot of really good
made-for-tv movies were made in that era
I'm not sure what was going on in the
70s but then well there was a lot of
good writers working and [ __ ] like that
I mean you had I mean this was directed
by Dan Curtis who obviously probably
most famous for dark shadows he also
directed burnt offerings he did Kolchak
The Night Stalker he did that 1974
Dracula the one I think that was the one
that had Jack Palance in it yeah yeah he
directed that as well and as I said the
three segments of this were based on
Richard Matheson stories now the third
one with the Zuni Warrior the segments
called Emilia even though the story that
it's based on is actually called pray
yeah but um Richard Matheson actually
wrote the teleplay for that one as well
but even though the other two were based
on his stories the guy that did the
teleplay for those was William F Nolan
who actually wrote the novel and Logan's
Run yeah okay
so you know and he wrote the screenplay
for burnt-offerings oh yeah it's good
it's a good flick and it's and you can
see it for free on YouTube
yeah it's up there so you know I don't
want to spoil everything about each each
each little tale because a lot of people
haven't seen this especially younger
people they've never seen this one
trilogy of terror yeah so you know them
in the first story is about a woman as a
schoolteacher and she's real kind of
uptight and proper and prim yeah she's
got the glasses yeah and everything like
a minute and she's she's a she's you
know she's teaching into college yeah
it's look at English too yeah and what
in one of the college kids you know he's
like this suckin dick slinger all he
does is just knock down women chad
McDade yeah yeah chad McDade McDade
great he get he's checking around he's
going like I wonder what she looks like
with those clothes off that he's saying
it to his buddies say he hatches this
plan to
to to get it and then to abuse it yeah
it's pretty it's some pretty horrible is
yeah I don't know if I should spoil
everything about that one but yeah
because um pretty much all of them I
don't know if you'd call this they kind
of have twist it twist annex then the
second one is about these two sisters
this this woman who's having a proper
shoes like in the same kind of deal I
guess prim proper checking living in
this mansion and she keeps having the
problem there's [ __ ] ass sister they
do different things and then you find
out real quick your real soon that you
know you can obviously tell what's going
on is that they're the same woman that
this that she's got yeah
she's gods but personality disorder
that's not really spoiling it because
that's not much fun I mean it's like
that might have been like more of a
surprise back in 1975 but it's done it's
been done to death like so many times
since then that it's like you will be
able to its telegraphed like I said I
Telegraph that [ __ ] mile away the ending
a the first one I'm not sure actually I
think the first time I saw that maybe I
didn't know health and I was gonna come
I actually didn't see that coming yeah
you see like how the twisted I mean the
last ones more kind of like an action
segment so there isn't any real there
isn't really any story to it other than
that this girl keeps getting pestered by
her mom
yeah interestingly the last segment is
almost like a one-woman play yeah
because you don't see anyone else she's
just in her apartment and she talks to
her mom on the phone and she talks to
her boyfriend on the phone but there's
nobody else you don't see anybody else
in the yeah in the apartment well she's
got this damn African doll it's kind of
like supposed to be a it looks like a
warrior it's got a bunch of teeth on it
and elongated head real demonic looking
and crazy hair to steer and be super
cute I think sharp teeth and big old
angry eyes and it supposedly has a damn
soul of a person trapped in it yeah he
who kills yeah yeah so it's you know I
guess she explains it in the movie
I guess you know you get an evil person
can soul can be captured and gets
imprisoned inside this little doll and
she doesn't believe it I don't think
well she just bought it at a curio shop
her boyfriend because he's an
anthropologist and I guess that's kind
of his bag so she like bought it for him
for his birthday that's how she is yeah
well this thing comes to life and I
don't really know why it came to life I
don't remember that well his little um a
gold chain that's right it had a neck
and it even said hey keep that gold
tuned on there because that's what's
keeping the warrior soul intact and it
fell off like it broke I forgot that
deep while she was like in the kitchen
cooking or something like that and then
she comes back in and he's not on the
coffee table anymore and that last story
she's being hunted down by this little
damn doll and most the time it's just in
the camera I know he makes the greatest
weird noises
it's got knives and she's trying to
outsmart it it's out so this big cat and
mouse game inside her house since it's
getting full-size knives its stabbing
her with a damn it's like stamping or
ankles that's definitely that it's like
it's just tries to drown it in a bathtub
yes tries put it in a suitcase all kind
of stuff happens it's just yeah it's um
I have to say that for 1975 best one it
actually well I think everybody says
that um and and I would agree with that
also was most memorable yeah I mean for
1975 the the little Zuni warrior like
looks good I mean yeah you gotta buy the
bathtub you can tell I could go with
editing and it's probably like a puppet
and stuff like that but it's like it
looked really good it looked really good
nice to see some stuff with the editing
and and it they didn't show it from you
didn't show movin yeah it was really
they show up moving and renting long
shots there real quick takes yeah I
think the longest they ever showed it
moving really was coming about a bathtub
one yeah that was yeah it was crawling
up out of the bathtub yeah which I
actually really liked that so they must
have had they must have had some really
um really thin solid wires kind of like
he did doing the arms and the legs yeah
I was thinking maybe it was a hand
puppet but I think his little arms are
too skinny yeah i fir it to be a hand
yeah it didn't really look like a hand
economy more like a marionette a
marionette on rods really really ski
that's probably what it was something
that would show up on film yeah yeah but
I think that's like I mean everybody
points to that last segment you know
just because the zuni's like little
warriors like so scary like his little
face is scary and also the you know it's
it's a really good like buildup of
tension like she's just on there on the
phone there's this little doll and
everything and then she's like she has
this conversation with her mom and and
all this other kind of stuff so there's
that kind of tension there and then you
know when she's in the kitchen and then
she kind of hears something and she
looks and this just this little bit of
shadow like goes by so it's like really
good at like building up like suspense
and not really showing the little guy
like as he's kind of like it's about
like a good Twilight Zone episode yeah
that's pretty much but like a lot of
these are like um as I said I think
probably I mean the third ones obviously
the best one that's the one everybody
remembers um I think probably the first
one which is called Julie about the
teacher that gets blackmailed into a
sexual yeah weird sexual thing with
[ __ ] Chad yeah Chad McDade Chad's
lasered [ __ ] yeah and like I said it
does have a twist ending which I
probably won't spoil oh I did want to
say that at one point in that segment
cuz I had to I had to look this up
because I wasn't sure where they go to a
drive-in theater like the drive-in
theater where he were he liked drugs or
drinking [ __ ] um so he was like making
this big deal about what's oh there's
this like French vampire arty French
vampire movie like playing at the
drive-in or whatever so I'm watching it
I'm like god that looks so familiar so I
looked at what it was
it's Kolchak The Night Stalker which is
another one of Dan Curtis movie okay but
it was the French dub of it all right so
he was like making fun of his own movies
because the guy at one point was saying
something like man I thought it's so
boring
you know so I thought that was like a
really cute like in joke that they put
in there that that was like one of his
other yeah and like I said I've seen
Kolchak The Night Stalker he made
another one too Kolchak the bull the
night strangler I guess it was like but
he did one about like I think that one
was about a werewolf but the the Night
Stalker was about vampire but um
yes so you know this is definitely keep
in mind that it's you know the 1970s and
[ __ ] like that but man is TV yeah I mean
if it's like a racy for TV it is
actually yeah there well a lot of it I
mean obviously they had to like
suggestive Gina's was talking about but
you know I mean anybody would know what
they were talking about particularly the
first one cuz I assumed that that's what
you were talking about now the
interesting thing about this too is that
I was going to say that a lot of the in
the last segment with the zany warrior
like where Karen black is like talking
on the phone and [ __ ] like that most of
that was improvised
also the last the very famous last shot
of that segment with Carrie wax face and
[ __ ] like that which you know it's it's
hard to say like oh I can't spoil it
because that's the picture that's like
on the front of the new blue right yeah
I think so it's not you're not really
spoiling anything but I think according
to her that that was her idea as well
and it's funny because ironically she
did not want to do this movie at first
um because she was afraid of getting
typecast which actually she kind of did
because after she did this then she was
doing like burnt offerings and then she
ended up you know and then much later
unless she got to you know she kind of
went more into a horror thing which I'm
not really sure because previous to that
she'd been in like I said something like
really big like a really big Hollywood
movies like Easy Rider and stuff like
that so yeah I think she was kind of
upset that she got typecast into horror
films yeah she was just lucky to
continue working though because yeah
think about you know most actresses and
actors just kind of vanished after a
movie or two that's true got to do
movies her whole life maybe maybe kind
of being forced into the horror role but
have been promoted longevity of her
career because you know lady ladies
don't last long they really don't and
it's like and I mean she was at shinu's
even in the [ __ ] Rob Zombie movies
and [ __ ] like that so like later on and
the thing about it is that you know
i-i-i it's hard for me to say because i
love horror movies but i know that there
are some actors that it's like oh they
don't want to do her because it's like
you know then that's all they'll be in
his horror movies and [ __ ] like that but
i have
one like I said it's probably regular
work maybe more than other genres to it
might not be as like glamorous or I
think it's as lucrative as lucrative or
as famous or anything like that but I
tell you what like horror fans are
really loyal and if you like get kind of
an itch like Karen black ad where she's
kind of like you know a scream queen
type of woman or she was in like a lot
of kind of cult horror movies it's like
you will have a built-in audience
forever yeah it's like you know what I
mean like even like younger people will
know your [ __ ] and say oh that doesn't
have a fear leading lady no not really
it's like it there's very few genres
where that happens so it's like if some
money I mean if I was an actor and
people like you know if you got typecast
into [ __ ] [ __ ] or I'd be like good
you know you might not make a billion
dollars but these should be remember at
least you'll be remembered and like
you'll have a lot of fans like forever
and [ __ ] like that for the rest of your
life yeah that's like you know what I
mean it's there's no shame in that it's
like you know you have all these people
come here for you I mean they want a 50
million dollar head you know I know that
but you know what I mean now I wanted to
talk about to when I didn't even know
this until today but in 1996 there was a
made-for-tv sequel to trilogy of terror
trilogy of terror - and it was also
directed by Dan Curtis and I thought
this was kind of interesting because I
actually it's on it's also on YouTube
for free because I found it and I said
oh I'll watch it today just you know
before we record this it had the same
kind of thing it was three stories it
was a different actress obviously it was
a Lissette Anthony who I knew from the
Dark Shadows reboot that happened in the
90s so she was in all three like playing
different characters now this one had
the first story I think was actually the
best one the graveyard rats and that was
a way M F Nolan story like I said he's
the guy that wrote Logan's Run now the
second the second segment was Bobby
which was based on a story by Richard
Matheson and I'm watching it going
goddamn this story is so familiar
they've made this into a movie before
and sure enough in 1977 Dan Curtis had
made another
ecology film called dead of night oh my
goodness he had made another one called
dead of night that also had Bobby in it
and it was almost exactly the same so I
thought that was very odd and then the
third segment of the sequel was actually
called he who kills and it was basically
a direct sequel of Emilia slash prey
from the first movie
zooni where it's like yeah so basically
it was just like it picked up where the
ambulance and the cops and Karen blacks
boyfriend were coming to the apartment
and finding her and her dead mom in the
apartment after the zuni dollar killed
him and then they find the little baked
Zuni doll in the oven and they take it
to Lissa Anthony's character who's like
some kind of like forensic something or
other and you know it it was like almost
exactly the same like she did like yeah
it was pretty good but she did like
exactly the same [ __ ] that care of like
she put it in a box and she tried to
drown him and then she tell us up so
it's like and the ending was like pretty
much exactly the same so I thought it
was kind of I mean it was kind of neat
like to see the little Zuni doll again
and everything but I just I thought it
more with it yeah I said I thought they
could have like expanded a little
because it was basically like the exact
same story just like in a difference it
was like in a lab setting instead of an
apartment so with the different actors
so people wanted more in it and it
killed like a couple other people - yeah
people wanted more I guess so give more
of that but um other than that like I
said the graveyard rats was actually my
favorite segment I liked the Bobby
segment too but it's just like I
couldn't get into it because I'd already
seen it done before in dead of night and
it was pretty much identical yeah um so
you know but it's a it's a perfectly
good movie and its own right and like I
said it is also free on YouTube if you
want to check them out check them both
out have a double feature it's super fun
cuz man I love anthology movies yeah but
yeah so trilogy of terror the wonderful
Karen black who sadly passed away many
years ago she died 2013-2014 yes cancer
okay so that was kind of a shame but yes
and I know I've probably recommended
this before but if you like Karen black
go see another TV movie called the
strange possession of
is Oliver that is also on YouTube I
think it might be the same channel that
has that other one but that's like
really really good and actually it kind
of reminds me of the middle segment of
trilogy of terror like the Millicent and
Therese I think that's called it's kind
of a similar thing to that which is she
was good that round saw a movie - yeah I
have to say I really did like I was very
excited she was one of those who choose
in both um I remember well thank you
just in one of those [ __ ] I don't even
remember I remember she was in the first
one I don't even remember she was in the
second one or not it's been so long
since I've seen him but yeah
alright so trilogy of chair terror go
check them out though we'll see you next
time bye